so I'm here to talk to you about the
lockable city
what is the lockable city well for want
of a better definition it's a city in
which the car is a optional instrument
of freedom rather than a prosthetic
device and I like to talk about why we
need the walkable city and I like to
talk about how to do the walkable city
most of the talks I give these days are
about why we need it but you guys are
smart and also I gave that talk exactly
a month ago and you can see it at
ted.com so today I want to talk about
how to do it in a lot of time thinking
about this I've come up with what I call
the general theory of walkability a bit
of a pretentious term it's a little
tongue-in-cheek but it's something I've
thought about for a long time and I like
to share what I think I've figured out
in the American city the typical
American city the typical American city
is not Washington DC or New York or San
Francisco it's Grand Rapids or Cedar
Rapids or Memphis but in the typical
American city in which most people own
cars and the temptation is to drive them
all the time
if you're going to get them to walk then
you have to offer a walk that's as good
as a drive or better what does that mean
it means that you need to offer four
things simultaneously there needs to be
a proper reason to walk the walk has to
be safe and feel safe the walk has to be
comfortable and the walk has to be
interesting you need to do all four of
these things simultaneously and that is
the structure of my talk today so take
you through each of those the reason to
walk is a story I learned from my
mentors Andres Duany and Elizabeth
Plato's I Burke the founders of the New
Urbanism movement and I'm should say
half the slides and half of my talk
today I learned from them it's the story
of planning the story of the formation
of the planning profession when in the
in the 19th century people were choking
from the soot of the dark satanic Mills
and the planners said hey let's move the
housing away from the mills and
lifespans increased immediately
dramatically and we like to say the
planners have been trying to repeat
that experience ever since so there's
the onset of what we call Euclidian
zoning the separation of the landscape
into large areas of single use and
typically when I arrive in a city to do
a plan a plan like this already awaits
me on the property that I'm looking at
and on a plan like this guarantees is
that you will not have a walkable city
because nothing is located near anything
else the alternative of course is our
most walkable city and I like to say you
know this is a Rothko and this is a
Syrah it's just a different way he was
the pointillist right it's a different
way of making places and even this map
of Manhattan is a bit misleading because
the red color is uses that are mixed
vertically so this is the big story of
the new Urbanists is to acknowledge that
there are only two ways two ways that
have been tested by the thousands to
build communities in the world and
throughout history one is the
traditional neighborhood you see here
several neighborhoods of Newburyport
Massachusetts which is defined as being
compact and being diverse places to live
work shop wreck create get educated all
within walking distance and it's defined
as being walkable there are lots of
small streets each one is comfortable to
walk on and we contrast that to the
other way an invention that happened
after the Second World War
suburban sprawl clearly not compact
clearly not diverse and it's not
walkable because so few of the streets
connect that those streets that do
connect become overburdened and you
wouldn't let your kid out on them and I
want to thank Alex McClane the aerial
photographer for many of these beautiful
pictures that I'm showing you today so
it's fun to break sprawl down into its
constituents parts it's so easy to
understand the places where you only
live the places where you only work the
places where your only shop and our
super-sized public institutions schools
get bigger and bigger and therefore
further and further from each other and
the ratio of the size of the parking lot
of this school to the size of the school
tells you all you need to know about
this school which is that no child has
ever walked to the school no child will
ever walk to the school the the seniors
and juniors are driving the freshman and
the sophomores and of course we have the
crash statistics to prove it and then
the super sizing
of our other civic institutions like
playing fields and it's wonderful that
you know Weston in fort lot in the fort
lauderdale area has 8 soccer fields and
8 baseball diamonds and you know 20
tennis courts but look at the road that
takes you to that location and would you
let your child bike on it and this is
why we have the soccer mom now when I
was young I had one soccer field and one
baseball diamond in one tennis court but
I could walk to it because it was in my
neighborhood and then the final part of
sprawl that everyone forgot to count
which is if you're going to separate
everything from everything else and
reconnect and only with automotive
infrastructure then this is what your
landscape begins to to look like so the
main message here is that if you want to
have a walkable city you can't start
with the sprawl model you need the bones
of an urban model you know this is the
outcome of that form of design as is
this and this is something that a lot of
Americans want but we have to understand
it's a two part American dream if you're
dreaming for this then you're also going
to be dreaming of this often too absurd
extremes when we build our landscape to
accommodate cars first and then the
experience of being in these places this
is not Photoshop
Walter Coolidge took this slide it's
it's in Panama City this isn't this is a
real place and being a driver can be a
bit of a nuisance and being a pedestrian
can be a bit of a nuisance in these
places this is a slide that
epidemiologists have been showing for
some time now and the fact that we have
a society where you drive to the parking
lot to take the escalator to the
treadmill shows that we're doing
something wrong but we know how to do it
better so here are the two models
contrasted and I show this slide which
has been a formative document of the new
urbanism now for almost 30 years to show
that that sprawl and the traditional
neighborhood contain the same things
it's just how big are they and how close
are they to each other and how are they
interspersed together and do you have a
street network rather than a cul-de-sac
or a collector system of streets so when
we look at a downtown area at a place
that has a hope of being walkable and
mostly that's our downtown's in
America's cities and neighbor and towns
and villages we look at them and we say
we want the proper balance of uses so
what is missing or underrepresented and
again in the typical American cities in
which most Americans live it is housing
that is lacking the jobs to housing
balance is often you find that when you
bring housing back these other things
start to come back too and housing is
usually first among those things and of
course finally the thing that shows up
lasts and eventually is the schools
because the people have to move in the
young you know pioneers have to move in
get old or have kids and fight and then
the schools get pretty good eventually
the other part of this of this part the
use the useful city part is transit and
you know you can have a perfectly
walkable neighborhood without it but
perfectly walkable cities require
transit because if you don't have access
to the whole city as a pedestrian then
you get a car and if you get a car the
city begins to reshape itself around
your needs and the streets get wider and
the parking lots get bigger and you no
longer have a walkable city so transit
is essential but every transit
experience every transit trip begins or
ends as a walk and so we have to
remember to build walkability around our
transit stations next category the
biggest one is the safe walk it's what
most walkability experts talk about it
is essential but alone not enough to get
people to walk and there are so many
moving parts that add up to a walkable
city the first is block size this is
Portland Oregon famously 200-foot blocks
famously walkable this is Salt Lake City
famously 600 foot blocks famously
unlockable and if you look at the - it's
almost like two different planets but
these places were both built by humans
and in fact the the story is that when
you have a 200 foot block city you can
have a two-lane city or a 2 to 4 Lane
City and a 600 foot block city is a
six-lane City and that's a problem these
are the crash statistics when you
doubled the block size this is a study
of 24 California cities when you double
the block size you quadruple almost
quadruple the number of fatal accidents
on non-highway streets so how many lanes
do we have this is where I'm gonna tell
you what I tell every audience I meet
which is to remind you about induced
demand an induced demand applies both to
highways and to city streets and what an
induced a man tells us is that when we
widen the streets to accept the
congestion that we're anticipating or
the additional trips that we're
anticipating
in congested systems it is principally
that congestion that is constraining
demand and so that the widening comes
and there are all these latent trips
that are ready to happen people move
further from work and they make other
choices about when they commute and
those lanes fill up very quickly with
traffic so we widen the street again and
they fill up again we've learned that
within congested systems we cannot
satisfy the automobile this is from
Newsweek magazine hardly an esoteric
publication today's engineers
acknowledge that building new roads
usually makes traffic worse and my
response to reading this was may I
please meet some of these engineers
because these are not the ones that I
typically there are great exceptions
that I'm working with now but these are
not the engineers that one typically
meets working in a city where they say
oh that road is too crowded we need to
add a lane so you add a Lane and the
traffic comes and they say see I told
you we needed that Lane so this applies
both to highways and to city streets if
they're congested but the amazing thing
about most American cities that I work
in the more typical cities is they have
a lot of streets that are actually
oversized for the congestion they're
currently experiencing this was the case
in Oklahoma City when the mayor came
running to me very upset because they
were named in Prevention magazine the
worst city for pedestrians in the entire
country now that can't possibly be true
but it certainly is enough to make a
mayor do something about it and we did a
walkability study and what we found
looking at the car counts on the street
these are three thousand four thousand
seven thousand car counts and we know
that two lanes can handle ten thousand
cars per day so look at these numbers
right they're all near or under ten
thousand cars and these were the these
were the streets that were designated in
the new downtown plan to be four lanes
to six lanes wide so you had a
fundamental disconnect between the
number of lanes and the number of cars
that wanted to use them so it was my job
to redesign every street in the downtown
from curb face to curb face and we did
it for fifty blocks of streets and we're
rebuilding it now so a typical you know
oversized Street to to know where is
being narrowed and now under
construction and the project is half
done the typical street like this you
know when you do that you find room for
medians you find room for
bike lanes we've doubled the amount of
on street parking we've added a full
bike Network we're wanting didn't exist
before but not everyone has the money
that Oklahoma City has because they have
a extraction economy that's doing quite
well
the typical city is more like Cedar
Rapids where also they have a all
four-lane system half one-way system and
it's a little hard to see but what we've
done what we're doing it's in process
right now it's in engineering right now
is turning a all four-lane system half
one-way into a all two-lane system all
two-way and in so doing we're adding
seventy percent more on street parking
which the merchants love and it protects
the sidewalk that parking makes the
sidewalk safe and we're adding a much
more robust bicycle Network then the
lanes themselves how wide are they
that's really important the standards
have changed such that as Andres Duany
says the typical road to a subdivision
in America allows you to see the
curvature of the earth this is a
subdivision outside of Washington from
the 1960s looked very carefully at the
width of the streets this is a
subdivision from the 1980s 1960s 1980s
the standards have changed to such a
degree that mild neighborhood of South
Beach when it was time to fix the street
that wasn't draining properly they had
to widen it and take away half our
sidewalk because the standards were
wider right people go faster on wider
streets people know this the engineers
deny it but the citizens know it so that
in Birmingham Michigan they fight for
narrower streets Portland Oregon
famously walkable instituted it's skinny
streets program in its residential
neighborhood we know that skinny streets
are safer the developer Vince Graham in
his project I on which we worked on in
South Carolina he goes to conferences
and he shows his amazing 22 foot roads
these are two-way roads very narrow
rights-of-way and he shows this
well-known philosopher who said broad is
the road that leads to destruction
narrow is the road that leads to life
and this
this plays very well in the south now
bicycles bicycles and bicycling are the
current revolution underway in only some
American cities but where you build it
they come and as a planner I hate to say
that but the one thing I can say is that
bicycle population is a function of
bicycle infrastructure I asked my friend
Tom Brennan from Nelson Nygaard in
Portland to send me some pictures of the
Portland bike commute and he sent me
this and I said was that bike to work
day and he said no that was Tuesday when
you do what Portland did and you spend
money on bicycle infrastructure in New
York City has doubled the number of
bikers in it several times now by
painting these bright green lanes even
automotive cities like Long Beach
California vast uptick in the number of
bikers based on the infrastructure and
of course what really does it if you
know 15th Street here in Washington DC
please meet Rahm Emmanuel's new bike
lanes in Chicago the buffered lane the
parallel parking pulled off the curb the
bikes between the cars and the parked
cars and the curb these mint cyclists if
however as in Pasadena every Lane is a
bike lane then no Lane is a bike lane
and this is the only bicyclists that I
met in Pasadena so the parallel parking
I mentioned it's an essential barrier of
steel that protects the curb and
pedestrians from moving vehicles this is
Fort Lauderdale one side of the street
you can park the other the street side
of the street you can't this is happy
hour on the parking side this is sad
hour on the other side and then this the
trees themselves trees slow cars down
they move slower when trees are next to
the road and of course sometimes they
slow down very quickly all the little
details the curb return radius is at one
foot or is it 40 feet how swoopy is that
curb to determine how fast the car goes
and how much room you have to cross and
then I love this because this is
objective journalism
some say the entrance to city centre is
not inviting to pedestrians when every
aspect of the landscape is swoopy is
aerodynamic is stream form geometrics it
says this is a vehicular place so no one
detail no one specialty can be allowed
set the stage and here you know this
street yes it will drain within a minute
of the hundred year storm but this poor
woman has to mount the curb every day so
then quickly the comfortable walk has to
do with the fact that all animals seek
simultaneously prospect and refuge we
want to be able to see our predators but
we also want to feel that our flanks are
covered and so we're drawn to places
that have good edges and if you don't
supply the edges people won't want to be
there what's the proper ratio of height
to width is it 1 2 1 3 2 1 if you get
beyond 1 2 6 you're not very comfortable
anymore you don't feel enclosed now 6 2
1 and Saltzburg can be perfectly
delightful the opposite of Salzburg is
Houston
right the point being the parking lot is
the principle problem here however
missing teeth
those empty Lots can be issues as well
and if you have a missing corner because
of an outdated zoning code then you
could have a missing nose in your
neighborhood that's what we had in my
neighborhood this was the zoning code
that said I couldn't build on that site
as you know DC is now or you may know
Washington DC is now changing its zoning
to allow sites like this to become sites
like this we needed a lot of variances
to do that triangular houses can be
interesting to build but if you get one
built people generally liked it so I've
got to fill those missing noses and then
finally the interesting walk signs of
humanity you know we are among the
social primates nothing interests us
more than other people we want signs of
people so the perfect one-to-one ratio
it's a great thing this is Grand Rapids
a very walkable city but nobody walks on
this street that connects the two best
hotels together because on the left
you know if on the left you have a
exposed parking deck and on the right
you have a conference facility that was
apparently designed in admiration for
that parking deck then you don't attract
that many people mayor Jill Riley and
his 10th term mayor of Charleston South
Carolina taught us and only takes 25
feet of building to hide 250 feet of
garage this one I call the chia pet
garage it's in South Beach that active
ground floor and then this is I'm going
to end with this project that I love to
show it's by Malecha architects it's in
Columbus Ohio to the left is the
convention center neighborhood full of
pedestrians to the right is the Short
North neighborhood as
great restaurants great shops struggling
and it wasn't doing very well because
this was the bridge and no one was
walking from the Convention Center into
that neighborhood well when they rebuilt
the highway they added an extra 80 feet
to the bridge sorry they rebuilt the
bridge over the highway the city paid
1.9 million dollars
they gave the site to the develop to a
developer the developer built this and
now the Short North has come back to
life and everyone says the newspapers
not the planning magazines the
newspapers say it's because of that
bridge so that's it that's the general
theory of walkability think about your
own cities think about how you can apply
it you've got to do all four things at
once so find those places where you have
most of them and fix what you can fix
what still needs fixing in those places
I really appreciate your attention and
thank thank you for for coming today